[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce premier journal de la saison 20
minutes d'information locale préparé par
la rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le
lundi 6 septembre voici les titres de
votre journal
près d'un million d'euros c'est la somme
que la région ile-de-france va donner au
nouveau quartier de gally à versailles
un investissement qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre du dispositif quartier innovants
et écologiques des jeux paralympiques se
sont achevées à tokyo hier soir la
france arrive à la 14ème place du
tableau avec 54 médailles la joueuse de
tennis charlotte fairbank serait avec
nous pour nous parler de son parcours
retour également sur la compétition avec
le bilan yvelinois dans cette édition et
puis légendes du septième art jean paul
belmondo vient de s'éteindre ce lundi 6
septembre nous reviendrons sur ses liens
avec le département de son enfance à
quarantaine au tournage de quelques-uns
de ses films
à l' usine renault de flins la
production de véhicules est suspendue
depuis le vendredi 3 septembre un arrêt
de l'activité engendrés par la pénurie
mondiale de semi conducteurs en
provenance d'asie des composants
électroniques essentiels pour le secteur
automobile la majorité des employés du
site sont concernées avec les production
de la zoé le principal véhicule
électrique du groupe nissan micra
l'activité devrait reprendre ce mercredi
8 septembre l'interview der président
des représentants du groupe renault par
nicolas landry il ya eu 1 c'est ce qui a
donc annoncé la fermeture trois jours
vendredi
lundi et mardi pour les sites de flammes
la difficulté c'est que on a aucune
perspective concernant
les
les arrivées de deux pièces les banques
pièce les sites d'ingénierie dans les 78
villiers saint frédéric et
et le thème nos sens calvet en cours qui
ont repris une activité pleine mais
revanche effectivement le c'est la
production qui est né le courtemanche
touchés
pour rappel l'usiné renault de flins va
connaître une réorientation stratégique
les dirigeants du groupe ont décidé de
transformer le site en stoppant la
production de véhicules consacré à
l'économie circulaire il accueillera
plusieurs activités notamment le
reconditionnement de véhicules et le
recyclage des batteries
à versailles à présent 540 logements une
école ou encore une ferme verront
bientôt le jour dans un nouvel
écoquartier près d'un million d'euros
vont être donnés par la région ile de
france pour soutenir ce projet ce projet
reportage de célia gars tsongo et céline
charles près d'un million d'euros c'est
le montant de la subvention versée par
la région ile de france pour la création
d'un nouvel écoquartier à versailles
appelée quartier de gally la signature
officielle a eu lieu vendredi 3
septembre sur ce nouveau site 140
logements une école une micro ferme une
crèche montessori et des commerces pour
voir le jour notre région a besoin des
70000 logements neufs par an mais
connaissant une croissance démographique
de 50 mille francs si bien chaque année
et donc nous avons besoin de logements
pour permettre aux gens de vivre
dignement tout proche du domaine du
château de versailles est limitrophe à
saint-cyr-l'ecole ce nouveau quartier
s'inscrit dans le dispositif sanscartier
innovants et écologiques mises en place
par la région ile de france celle ci a
déjà labellisé 57 quartier pour
l'obtenir plusieurs critères dont
l'importance des espaces de nature avec
la création à versailles d'une cité
fertile puisque le nouveau quartier ne
doit pas être visible depuis le château
de versailles donc toute une logique
avec
et masques végétaux qui vont être passés
entre le parc du château et les futurs
bâtiments et on va être vraiment dans un
espace de nature très bien pensé avec
une grande exigence architecturale ce
terrain de 20 hectares est construit sur
l'ancienne caserne militaire de pions
les travaux devraient débuter dans les
mois à venir puisque le quartier de
gally devra en partie être prêt pour les
jeux olympiques de 2024 les épreuves
d'équitation se dérouleront à quelques
centaines de mètres de là le projet
global devra être terminée lui en 2027
un point sur la situation sanitaire à
présent à savoir que l'épidémie recul le
pic de la quatrième vague est passée
dont les yvelines jeudi et le taux
d'incidence était de 147 contre un peu
plus de 170 à la semaine précédente soit
une baisse de 17% hier le nombre
d'hospitalisations dans le département
s'élevait à 156 dont 30 en réanimation
en moyenne chaque jour une personne
décède de l'aco vide à l'hôpital 8
retourne à domicile
[Musique]
ça y est le compte à rebours pour paris
2024 est officiellement lancée les jeux
paralympiques de tokyo se sont refermées
ce dimanche avec la cérémonie de clôture
au stade olympique de la ville la maire
de paris anne hidalgo a reçu le drapeau
paralympique a désormais trois ans des
jeux dans la capitale et la région ile
de france grégory canal est journaliste
pour télé 78 bonsoir vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir le sun et justement c'est
l'occasion de dresser le bilan de cet
événement avec tout d'abord ce chiffre
54 54 médailles ont été glanées par la
délégation française durant les 13 jours
de compétition est dans le détail 11 en
or 14 en argent et 28 en bronze
l'objectif fixé a été pulvérisée
puisqu'il était de 35 médailles au total
à la france termine 14e et a fait bien
mieux que les 28 médailles obtenues à
rio 2016 et dépasse même les 52
médailles de pékin 2008 et parmi elles
les athlètes les plus en lumière le
cycliste alexandre les hôtes et 20 ans
porte drapeau lors de la cérémonie de
clôture pour ses premiers jeux il a
décroché tout de même quatre médailles
dont une en or c'est vrai qu'en est-il
de nosy be no engagés grégory thil ont
brillé justin est justement dans les
épreuves de cyclisme à elle seule qui
ont drainé 28% des médaillés tricolores
un nom à retenir celui de marie
patouillet 33 ans natif de versailles et
qui a exercé comme médecin généraliste
dans les yvelines c'est elle qui a
obtenu la première médaille française à
tokyo avec d'abord le bronze en
poursuite individuelle et puis la
cycliste a récidivé une semaine plus
tard avec un nouveau bond sur route pour
la course en ligne à c4 et c5 et puis
enfin deux quatrièmes places en contre
la montre et en 500 m contre la montre
également et en natation aussi le
département a brillé il a été au premier
plan oui avec le club saint germanois du
cercle des nageurs de l'ouest 1 qui
avait sa figure de proue pour ces jeux
de tokyo c'est alex portal 19 ans en
lice dans cinq épreuves rien que ça ça
jeunesse et le fait que ce soit comme
marie patouiller à une première dans ces
jo ne lui ont pas fait peur médaille
d'argent sur le 200 m 4 nages bronze au
400 m nage libre s 13 4e place au 100 m
papillon il paraissait tout de même déçu
au sortir de ces épreuves et ne cache
pas ses ambitions pour paris 2024 elles
deux médailles donc tout comme hugo
didier 19 ans aussi originaire des
yvelines natif du chesnay est licencié
désormais dans un club de haute-garonne
l'argent au 400 m nage libre est neuf et
le bronze en 200 m 4 4 nages sm 9
présent avec deux sportifs qui ont été
sociétaire de club yvelinois par le
passé timothée adolphe 31 ans né à
versailles qui a habité à guyancourt il
a débuté l'athlétisme
cinquième à rio disqualifié pour ces
jeux de tokyo en séries du 400 m il a
pris sa revanche sur le 100 m -t 11 une
première médaille en argent de l'année
aux côtés de son guide bruno n applique
ce et peut-être c'est l'une des grandes
déceptions de ces jeux paralympiques
nantenin keita 36 ans ex licenciés de le
à sky s'est lentement l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
elle a signé son meilleur temps de la
saison sur le 400 m haies 13 mais cela
n'a pas été suffisant pour obtenir une
médaille la tenant du titre en or à rio
2016 termine au pied du podium à la
quatrième place et on termine ce tour
d'horizon par les sports de raquette
deux premières également décidément
c'était une grande première pour de
nombreuses yvelinois sur ces jeux de
tokyo est déjà en para badminton alors
ce qu'il faut noter justin c'est que
c'était une première pour le para
badminton elle entrait à cette
discipline comme sport paralympique
cette année le numéro cinq mondial
mairie le caire 23 ans et arrêtée dès la
phase de groupes une victoire contre le
polonais aime rose avant de céder par
deux fois contre les indonésiens henry
mood 6 nuls gros qui obtiendront plus
tard respectivement la médaille d'argent
et la médaille de bronze donc c'était
aussi à des gros qui a affronté
l'yvelinois et enfin en tennis fauteuil
également charlotte faire banques
inquiète dans le top 40 mondial qui
s'entraînent à voisins le bretonneux
elles étaient engagés en simple et en
double deux défaites au premier tour
face à l'américaine mathewson en simple
1 6 0 à 6 3 et en double avec sa
compatriote emmanuel manche contre la
doublette du comité paralympique russe
avotvaz abuse nova en trois sets 6-2 5-7
2-6 merci grégory canal et d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir journaliste pour tv 78
et pour poursuivre sur les jeux
paralympiques charlotte ferland vous
avec nous bonsoir ben ça alors vous êtes
en visio puisque vous êtes à peine en
train de rentrer finalement vous êtes
arrivé sur paris en fin d'après midi
vous vous entraînez à voisins le
bretonneux quel bilan faites-vous de
votre parcours à tokyo
ah on me dit que vous êtes sous le
tunnel charlotte
[Musique]
j'arrivais yahia très j'atterris à trac
qu'est ce que vous faites de quel bilan
vous faites de votre parcours à tokyo
on reviendra vers vous tout à l'heure
puisque apparemment vous êtes sous le
tunnel côté
merci on vous reprend tout à l'heure un
côté sport les rendez-vous aux amateurs
reprennent petit à petit dans les
yvelines ce week-end place à la coupe de
france le deuxième tour de la
compétition se jouer sous une condition
les joueurs devaient présenter leurs
passes sanitaires pour être inscrit sur
leur feuille de match patrick jacques de
dixmude et bixente mais rien santesteban
sont allés voir le protocole du côté de
guyancourt regarder bonjour
merci bon match c'est un protocole
obligatoire pour lancer le coup d'envoi
de toute rencontre de football
professionnel comme amateur le pass
annie terre des joueurs est exigée avant
d'entrer sur la pelouse c'est nécessaire
pour la protection tout le monde donc il
faut qu'il arrive à le faire et c'est
bien pour nous parce que l'on peut
rejouer au foot malgré le bonheur de
pouvoir enfin participer aux
compétitions l attente attendu coupe de
france certains restent mitigés quant à
l'impact de cette décision sortir son
téléphone se faire contrôler tout ça
gâche la beauté du sport j'ai pas trop
pour ce dispositif est bon faut faire
avec c'est des restrictions qu'on a on
doit les accepter
c'est une perte de joueurs aussi parce
qu'il ya des joueurs qui sont contre
tout ce qui est vaccin test donc on perd
des joueurs aussi jusque ce soit chez
les adultes ou chez les jeunes encore
beaucoup plus chez les jeunes parce
qu'ils sont dépendants de leurs parents
cette perte de joueurs pourrait devenir
encore plus préoccupante dans les
semaines à venir très prochainement les
tests vont devenir payant donc ça va
être une autre problématique forcément
lorsqu'il y a des des licenciés ça
ramène bien évidemment à l'aspect
financier donc il ya beaucoup de clubs
qui risque malheureusement de mourir une
fois les dépistages co vite devenu
payant en octobre les joueurs non
vacciner devront payer entre 90 et 150
euros par semaine pour pouvoir
participer à tous les entraînements et
matchs de leur club de football
une rencontre qui a vu le s guyancourt
s'incliner sur le score 3 à 0 une fin de
parcours dès le deuxième tour pour le
club de saint quentinois dans cette
france côté résultats le week end a
souri à d'autres clubs de
l'agglomération un exploit d'abord pour
le voisin football club venu à bout de
grigny 1 0 alors que le club de
l'essonne évoluer deux divisions plus
haut ça passe également pour plaisir
maurepas trappe et montigny et quant à
la démonstration du week end elle est
signée saint germain en laye vainqueur
sur un score sans appel de 10 0 face aux
mimosas mada sport club du val de marne
les équipes qualifiées se donnent rendez
vous pour le troisième tour dès le 19
septembre
charlotte faire banquet ce qu'on vous a
récupéré bonsoir
du coup oui je lisais vous veniez de
tout juste de rentrer en fait de paris
d'où le fait que vous êtes dans la
voiture c'est sage h est vraiment de
retour on a atterri il ya trois-quatre
heures à roissy avec la moitié de la
délégation française et elle a donc je
rentre à la maison
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation j'imagine que vous êtes un
peu fatigué quel bilan faites-vous de
votre parcours à tokyo
je reste vraiment super positif c'était
vraiment une expérience incroyable oui
j'ai une défaite en simple et en double
au premier tour mais
mes jeux mais en fait j'avais page avait
pas d'objectif en arrivant en gilliot je
sais pas moi un objectif d'aller
chercher une médaille pas du tout parce
que je sais que ça mes premiers jeux et
j'ai encore beaucoup à apprendre donc
donc franchement une expérience
incroyable et puis avec toute l'équipe
de france et c'est que de l'expérience
acquise pour pour 2024 alors je le
rappelle pour ceux qui viennent de nous
rejoindre vous êtes championne de parra
tennis et c'était vos premiers jeux
olympique donc les résultats de vos
matchs vous venez d'en parler face à
cette première expérience donc dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes vous disiez vous
n'êtes pas finalement déçu puisque vous
n'attendiez pas forcément la médaille
c'était plus une expérience
voilà c'était vraiment enfin l'objectif
pour moi c'était vraiment de prendre du
plaisir un maximum de plaisir sur le
terrain en simple et en double avec avec
les manuels marche et voilà surtout de
profiter de m'enrichir en expérience
pour pour être prêt pour les jeux dans
trois ans cette année face aux
conditions sanitaires que l'on connaît
la compétition s'est déroulée à huis
clos selon vous est-ce que ça a pu avoir
un impact sur votre jeu
alors disons qu'en tennis fauteuil on
n'a pas énormément de public en général
qui regarde nos matchs donc ça c'était
l'aspect sans public ça nous a pas
tellement gêné c'était juste le fait que
en fait on n'a pas pu voir les autres
sports on n'a pas vraiment pu vivre dans
l'esprit olympique vraiment à 100% parce
que justement on était avec la
délégation française on pouvait pas
soutenir nos nouveaux collègues sur leur
discipline donc ça c'était un peu
dommage mais en ce qui concerne le
tennis ça m'a pas tant je n'ai que ça et
au niveau de l'ambiance sur place entre
les athlètes et aussi au village
olympique lors de la cérémonie de
clôture également comment c'était et
arrive vraiment une super ambiance après
c'est vrai que bon bah en comme je
disais en n'ayant pas pu voir les autres
disciplines ces tests et voilà il y
avait c'est un peu plus triste mais mais
non vraiment il y avait une super
ambiance on était tous dans une
résidence une seule résidence avec toute
la délégation on était les 140 athlètes
ensemble est
bon non
[Musique]
depuis ça ensemble de soutenir de les
manger ensemble tout seul à la non
c'était vraiment incroyable de
ça
donc et
aujourd'hui vous êtes si je ne dis pas
de bêtises 39e mondial ou 38e je ne sais
plus vous allez me re préciser votre
objectif est d'atteindre le top 38 yens
votre objectif c'est d'atteindre le top
10 mondial d'ici 2024 c'est ça que vous
disiez
c'est ça ce serait remet plus gros des
petits c'est ça en fait de l'arrivée
d'un top 10 même voir top 8 en fait en
tennis fauteuil pour faire lé grand
chelem il faut être dans le top 8
mondial cédé 13 pensez vraiment des
petits tableaux et donc donc un mais
objectif serait de faire un roulant et
pourquoi pas les autres grands chelems
et donc d'arriver dans le top 8 10 pour
pouvoir les faire
merci beaucoup charles hautes sphères
banque d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes champions n'ont pas
un tennis merci beaucoup machado merci
très bonne soirée il était monstre sacré
du cinéma l'acteur jean paul belmondo
est décédé ce lundi 6 septembre à l'âge
de 88 ans celui qu'on surnommait bébel a
vécu quelques années à clairefontaine en
yvelines son enfance pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale il était notamment
enfant de choeur à l'église il avait
tourné dans 80 films et des rôles
inoubliables pierrot le fou le
magnifique à bout de souffle encore un
singe en hiver ou itinéraire d'un enfant
gâté dont certaines scènes ont été
tournées au coeur du safari du zoo de
thoiry
et on retrouve en visio avec nous à
vincent mirabel bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes professeur de cinéma et auteur de
l'histoire du cinéma pour les nuls alors
vincent mirabel
vous avez appris cette nouvelle comme on
vous l'avait accueilli ce soir avec
beaucoup de tristesse figurez vous que
ce sont mes élèves qui m'ont informé ils
sont plus connectés que moi et ma foi
c'est tout une part de ma jeunesse qui
s'envole moi j'ai été baigné au film de
belmondo notamment dans les années
soixante dix où il représentait le flic
sans peur et sans reproche pour tout le
cinéma français populaire
selon vous quel héritage jean paul
belmondo laissera t-il à ce cinéma
français alors il paraît que le
président macron a qualifié belmondo de
trésor national
c'est une expression très forte et
effectivement perd qu'un forme de
trésors en tout cas quelqu'un de très
riche sa filmographie exemplaire c'est
quand même très de 90 films qui s'étale
sur 50 ans donc un demi siècle de cinéma
et il a travaillé avec les plus grands
donc de ce point de vue là del mondo
c'est une énorme figure du cinéma
français qui s'en va et il mérite un
très grand hommage c'était un homme
extrêmement et mais il était sympathique
et pourtant il avait initialement une
gueule particulière qui fait qu'on lui
prédisait un avenir assez limité et gras
à cause de sa gueule et surtout de sa
faconde et de sympathie il a réussi à
s'imposer donc belmondo c'est à la fois
de talent et du panache et de la
sympathie
et si vous deviez nous parler d'un film
donc tourné avec jean paul belmondo dans
les oreilles dans les yvelines ce serait
lequel alors il faut passer en revue la
grande liste des 90 films j'ai le
souvenir du film l'alpagueur qui est pas
le meilleur cru mais qui se passe à
carrières-sur-seine donc dans les
yvelines c'est un film de philippe labro
je crois que la neige devait noter 1976
il y joue le rôle de d'un certain roger
pinard qui en fait un surnom beaucoup
plus vendeur qui est l'alpagueur et qui
va alpaguer un baron de la drogue après
moult aventures voilà carrière sur scène
une tournée par philippe labro belmondo
a tourné toute façon dans toute la
france et même à l'international donc on
trouve des traces de lui partout
merci beaucoup vincent millet label
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir va je le
rappelle professeur de cinéma
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
demain vous retrouverez grégory canal et
à la présentation de votre journal local
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]